so now that we've looked specifically
at donald trump's press briefing
comments about the horrifying atlantic
story
which has now been quadruply
corroborated by the ap fox news and cnn
there's a ton of other material from
this weird press briefing that i want to
go over
especially because kamala harris in her
interview on cnn which we looked at
discusses a lot of the material from
this press briefing so
this first clip this is just incoherent
i don't know what trump is saying here
can you figure out what he's talking
about
now they want to stop regulations they
want to
bring up regulations to a level stop the
things that we're doing which are at a
much smaller level and bring up
regulations at a level that nobody's
ever seen before they want to do
i beg you try to figure out what donald
trump is talking about there
donald trump then absurdly claims
that economic shutdowns to combat the
virus
kill more people than the virus itself
now i'm going to deal with the numbers
in a moment first take a look at what
trump said
want to abolish american energy i mean
that's what's going to happen adopt
disastrous trade deals and inflict a
devastating shutdown
as you know he said we want to shut it
down we would be willing to shut it down
and you don't shut down when we're
setting records and by the way we're
rounding the corner
we're rounding the corner on the virus
joe biden's blanket shut down would
collapse our economy would cause
countless deaths from suicide drug
alcohol abuse heart disease and more you
know shutdowns
cause a lot of problems a lot of very
serious problems
more so than the virus itself so we're
approaching 200
000 deaths from coronavirus the
shutdowns
have obviously not caused 200 000 deaths
or anywhere close to it now
let's be thorough are deaths of despair
a thing
yes of course we've reported on that on
this program they've been a problem in
the united states
for economic reasons for a long time
deaths of despair are a real thing
can later diagnoses of cancer for
example
or other conditions because people are
opting out of going to the doctor right
now
can that lead to premature death of
course it can
of course can being in quarantine cause
somebody to commit suicide
it could happen but we've had 200
000 coronavirus deaths it's insulting to
suggest
that that is uh not as bad
as the number of deaths we've had due to
the shutdowns
it's ludicrous and it's laughable then
donald trump again suggests this idea
that states that are closed or closed
for political reasons to hurt him
and that the day after the election
they're all going to open take a look
north carolina i think that michigan
and pennsylvania and other states they
should open the governors a democrat
governor should open the states they'll
open them on november 4th
but that should open them now it's very
unfair to the people to have those
shutdowns continuing
at the level that they're continuing
democrats are insisting on it the
shutdowns
two things on this number one the
shutdowns aren't really continuing i
mean to different degrees even
massachusetts which is being very
careful and there's like sort of limited
indoor dining not every restaurant's
doing it
a lot of colleges are going remote
there's really no no full shutdowns
going on
at this point in time and of course the
shutdowns were not done for political
reasons
no governor is on november 4th going to
say
hey we can now open wide open now but we
can now open wide
that's another trump fantasy it's not
going to happen then trump spoke about
the vaccine again
this is tracking with a lot of what
kamala harris talked about in her
interview with cnn
trump says we can probably have the
vaccine
during october and you might have
noticed that trump's timeline for the
vaccine keeps getting pushed up more and
more
percent more greater excess mortality
than the united states a lot of you
don't want to report that
and if we took new york out of the
equation there's nobody even close the
job we've done
is incredible and we don't get any
credit for it
but we've done an incredible job through
operation warp speed we have
three vaccines in the final stage of
clinical trials yesterday pfizer
announced i just spoke to the head of
pfizer
great guy they announced that it expects
to have the results of its
trial very very shortly next month
but very shortly we remain on track to
deliver a vaccine before the end of the
year and maybe even before
november 1st we think we could probably
have it sometime
during the month of october and pfizer
is
among the leaders as you know kamala was
asked
would you trust a vaccine that a trump
fda approves in october
and she said i don't trust trump and it
is not about
anti-vaxxer it's about trump
being the constant liar then and this is
just
wild trump on social distancing listen
to this and i'll tell you why it's crazy
in a moment
and we need everybody to be careful to
apply common sense and
do all of the things that we've told you
to do
as quickly as much as you can
social distancing wearing a mask when
ever the distancing is not
possible and staying like
staying with a group that you know let's
just try and get through this
one weekend and i think we have a chance
of doing that just
social distance wash your hands all of
the hygiene things that we speak about
and we're really rounding the turn so
trump says that
but trump is doing rallies trump just
did a rally in latrobe pennsylvania
everybody's standing together no masks
huge crowd
no covid tests no hand washing everybody
crammed into a tight space to wait for
donald trump to show up
he's saying at press briefings masks
space between people all the stuff
and then he's holding optional events
where it is impossible to do it
lastly trump or a couple more clips
trump can't under
understand the english of the same
indian reporter
who's been there for years with the
press corps trump tells him he didn't
catch anything other than
india thank you mr president
bring the conventions uh
thank you in the conventions kimberly
and don julia
had the outreach to the indian americans
community with a video
called four more years for you which has
gone viral among
indian americans the battleground states
so my question is would kimberly don
junior and ivanka trump who are very
popular among indian americans
would be campaigning on your behalf
among the indian americans
with your views on india university
internship
well i i didn't understand everything
you said i know india
trump only understood india there you go
and then the reporter tries again
and all trump can say is he likes india
and they like him in india
and india is a very big country
so my question was about indian
americans do you think they are voting
for you for
are you are they supporting you i do we
had a an event
in houston as you know and it was a
fantastic event i was invited by
prime minister modi and this was a
massive this was at the
where they play football houston
football team
and it was uh it was it was incredible
it was actually incredible and
the prime minister could not have been
more generous we have
great support from india we have great
support from
prime minister modi and i would think
that the people
indian people would be voting for trump
i also as you know went to
india just prior to the pandemic setting
in because india's been hit very hard
left really about a week before that
and we had an incredible time what what
we saw the people are
so incredible it's really an incredible
place an incredible country
and it's definitely big it's definitely
big
trump also adds in that if the indian
people were given the opportunity they
would they would vote trump
this is indistinguishable from parity
this is impossible to satirize
what does how does snl make a parody
of a press briefing like that we cannot
withstand much more of this we really
can't we have to remove this guy